he was austria's gift to the world of
cinema arnold schwarzenegger back in
vienna
and taking center stage here he gathered
together politicians business leaders
and campaigners to talk climate change
and to vent his frustration look what
happened on
at the g7 summit do you see what
happened
nothing nothing
at the age of 73 he's become a
passionate activist
convinced that the key to solving
climate change doesn't just lie
in confronting political leaders it's a
very good solution but not the only one
we should also build a from the ground
up movement we should educate the public
so that they are with the programs that
they know what the dangers are
and the dangers that lie ahead and it
has nothing to do with politics it has
to do with one thing
let's go and get rid of pollution
because pollution
kills people the chinese and the indians
are
are putting out enormous amount of
issues emissions they're not
here is there any point in the sense of
of really a climate change policies that
don't
include those two giant industrial
nations well
i think that uh we shouldn't limit
ourselves
and to think that the only way we get
things done is if everyone is in on it
i don't remember john f kennedy saying
we are not going to send the man to the
moon unless the chinese also send a man
to the moon
unless the russians send the man to the
moon unless the european cinema
no he said we're going to be the first
ones and we're going to go and do it
so that's leadership but if that was a
sense
of purpose there was also anger and
frustration
and from greta turnburg contempt for
politicians
the gap between your actions and words
is becoming more impossible to ignore
while more and more extreme weather
events are raging all around us
and as a result young people all over
this planet
are no longer falling for your lies
there are plenty of differences between
timber and schwarzenegger
but they are also proof that climate
activism has become a broad global
church
adam parsons sky news vienna